imaginez vous faites une randonnée dans
les hautes montagnes après des heures de
marche vous vous éloignez un petit peu
du sentier et là vous découvrez un corps
encore figées dans la glace c'est ce qui
arrive à un couple de randonneurs en
1991 à la frontière de l'autriche cette
histoire est plus connu sous le nom de
la malédiction d'autres sites pourquoi
les personnes ayant approché cette momie
sont mortes peu de temps après qu'est ce
que cette momie faisait là emprisonné
dans un bloc de glace cette histoire a
fasciné fascine toujours des chercheurs
du monde entier compte il comme
information surprenante à nous dévoiler
pour répondre à ces questions je suis
accompagné de clotilde de la chaîne
passé sauvage qui marraine ce onzième
épisode bonjour à toutes et à tous ravis
de vous retrouver en compagnie de fabien
pour ce nouvel épisode cabinet curieuse
on va creuser ensemble le mystère de la
malédiction de 2,6 la célèbre momie des
glaces bienvenue tant cabinet curieux
[Musique]
revenons un peu en arrière
nous sommes le 19 septembre 1991 erika
et helmut un couple de randonneurs
décide d'aller faire une petite
randonnée dans le coeur des alpes de
l'ofc talent à la frontière autrichienne
à 3210 mètres d'altitude alors qu'il
s'éloigne un petit peu du sentier
principal ils font une découverte
terrifiante
encore emprisonnées dans la glace sur
l'instant le couple pense qu'il s'agit
d'un randonneur qui aurait été victime
d'un accident et qui serait mort de
froid que fait-on dans ces moments-là en
état de choc et de stupéfaction
rapidement il adopte un bon réflexe en
prévenant les autorités et en
photographiant le corps momifié le
lendemain un gendarme un gardien de
refuge tente de sortir le corps captif
de la glace à l'aide d'un marteau
piqueur la compression la tâche est
délicate et les deux hommes finissent
malheureusement par abîmer la momie à
certains endroits mais d'un point de vue
général elle est quasiment intact c'est
le début de la faire ainsi en référence
à la la les dates stahl près de laquelle
il a été retrouvé quelques jours plus
tard le 23 septembre la momie est enfin
dégagée les glaces peu après certaines
personnes commencent à identifier des
événements étranges des événements qui
seront perçues comme une malédiction
mais on reviendra dessus un peu plus
tard la momie est alors transporté
jusqu'à l'institut de médecine légale
d'innsbruck pour être mise entre les
mains de l'archéologue conrad spindler
on sait d'ores et déjà qu'il s'agit d'un
homme est sans doute pas d'un
randonneurs égarés mais la grande
question c'est depuis combien de temps
ce qu'en est il des analyses ont révélé
un chiffre nous dévoilant que le corps
était là depuis 5300 ans c'est
phénoménal on en sait d'ailleurs un peu
plus sur l'âge qu'il avait au moment de
sa mort 45 ce qui est fascinant c'est
que grâce à la glace la momie était
comme figé les vêtements et les objets
de l'homme n'ont pas bougé on a retrouvé
un arc en bois d'if massive des flèches
une hache ou encore une dague à la lame
de silex puisque le corps était plus ou
moins bien conserver les chercheurs ont
pu apprendre beaucoup d'autres choses
sur l'homme momifié son mode de vie sa
santé jusqu'à des détails parfois
surprenants clotilde qu'est ce qu'on
sait sur lui grâce à une étude adn
réalisés à partir d'échantillons de sang
de 3700 donneur anonyme
on sait que l'homme des glaces à des
cousins dans la région du tyrol
autrichien 19 de ses donneurs partagent
en effet un ancêtre commun avec petit
d'après le généticien walter personnes
un ancêtre qui aurait vécu il y a dix
mille à 12000 ans alors ça peut paraître
étonnant qu'on puisse en savoir autant à
partir d'une dépouille mais la grande
chance qu'on a avec le si c'est qu'on a
retrouvé les parties molles la peau
l'estomac et les intestins bref tout ce
qu'on a jamais en temps normal pour les
chercheurs da c'est plutôt une
bénédiction qu'une malédiction pour
l'instant on sait donc que cet homme
était intolérants au lactose qu'il avait
des calculs biliaires une maladie des
gencives décarie et même une
excroissance sur le petit orteil mais
c'est pas tout puisqu'on sait qu'il
était porteur de nombreux bactéries et
parasites dans son estomac on a retrouvé
la bactérie helicobacter pylori qui
provoque des brûlures il ya aussi des
oeufs de three kings qui donne la
trichinellose provoquant des fièvres et
diarrhées
la glace a aussi conservé des
médicaments préhistorique dans son
équipement les archéologues ont trouvé
notamment des polypes heures de boulot
un champignon qui servait à traiter ces
maladies on a un troisième élément
intéressant il était tatoué c'est le
nombre de tatouages repéré sur le corps
de cet homme et ceux de la tête aux
pieds des tatouages à cette époque c'est
assez étonnant comment est ce qu il s'y
prenait et bien tout simplement en
incisant finement la peau et en
remplissant ses incision de charbon pour
les chercheurs il ne s'agit pas
forcément de tatouage décoratifs comme
on fait aujourd'hui mais d'un signe de
pratiques d'acupuncture
rien n'est vraiment certain il ya
toujours des recherches là dessus mais
les tatouages sont en effet
essentiellement localisées sur des zones
sujettes à des douleurs comme le dos ou
les articulations son dernier repas
était d'un bouc
et oui les chercheurs ont même découvert
qu'il avait mangé du bouquetin ils ont
également retrouvé dans son estomac des
grains microscopiques de pollen au plus
exactement trente sortes de pollen
différentes cette information nous donne
une indication sur la saison à laquelle
serait mort aussi
et en parlant de son décès si cet homme
est à l'origine d'une malédiction
quelles sont les causes précises de sa
mort justement il aurait été assassiné
beaucoup de choses ont été dites sur les
circonstances de sa mort on pensait tout
d'abord qu'il était mort de froid a pris
dans une tempête de neige aujourd'hui on
s'accorde plutôt à penser qu'il s'est
battu et a été touché par un projectile
une flèche a en effet été retrouvées
fichiers derrière son épaule alors
peut-être pas morte elle cette blessure
témoigne quand même d'un affrontement
peu de temps avant sa mort d'autant que
des traces de sang ont été découvertes
sur deux des flèche de son carquois sur
sa cape et sur son poignard de silex les
analyses effectuées montrent que le sang
appartient à quatre personnes
différentes alors si était-il un sahel
killer n'a en tous cas ce n'était pas
spécialement un pacifiste bon cette
fameuse malédiction dans tout ça qu'en
est il
innocent hellmuth qui avait découvert la
momie et qui adore les excursions et ce
type de randonnée figurez-vous qu'il a
disparu dans une expédition qui l'a mené
en 2004 dans le même massif que celui où
ils avaient trouvé la mort lui qui était
si expérimenté n'est jamais revenu neuf
jours plus tard son corps a été
découvert et là vous allez me dire oui
mais c'est quoi le rapport avec la moe
lui rien à ce moment là personne ne fait
rien mais dans les années qui ont suivi
c'est vrai que plusieurs personnes ayant
approché la momie ont péri écoutez ce
que le magazine allemand der spiegel
explique soudain on s'est souvenu du
médecin légiste riner n qui avait
autrefois examiné petit et qui était
mort un an après lors d'un accident de
voiture
après lui venait un guide de haute
montagne qui était présent lors des
travaux d'extraction de la momie et qui
avait eu un accident mortel en montagne
le reporter de l'eau arf qui avait filmé
petit décédé d'un cancer et peu après la
mort d'anna de simone l'explorateur
spindler qui travaillent sur authie
décéda d'une sclérose en plaques ce
dernier déclara d'ailleurs avant sa mort
en plaisantant la motion victimes ce
sera peut-être le moins au total ce sont
sept personnes liées de près ou de loin
à auxi qui sont morts alors simple
coïncidence évidemment puisque aucune
raison objective ne permet de relier ces
décès paseo créé par les instruments les
plus modernes on sait que s'ils
n'étaient pas porteurs d'un thériault
virus les victimes ont d'ailleurs
succombé à des accidents ou des maladies
qu'elles avaient déjà contracté et puis
on ne parle pas des dizaines d'autres
personnes qui ont été en contact avec le
tice en souffrir d'aucun problème de
santé quoi qu'il en soit montrée sous un
certain angle les faits sont troublants
d'autant que ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'une momie est à l'origine d'une
rumeur malédiction celle de toutankhamon
découvert par howard carter en 1922
avait déjà beaucoup fait parler d'elle
de nombreuses personnes présentes lors
de l'ouverture du tombeau sont en effet
décédé dans les semaines et les mois qui
ont suivi popularisé par les amateurs de
paranormal la malédiction a sans doute
une explication bien plus prosaïque
l'histoplasmose une maladie provoquée
par les moisissures concentrés dans les
tombeaux et qui ont pu infecter les
poumons des archéologues
en tout cas on ne peut que souligner le
travail exceptionnel des scientifiques
en remontant jusqu'à 5000 ans en arrière
ils ont été capables d'analyser la
dépouille dans ses moindres détails et
puis et jusqu'à la tête jusqu'à
connaître le contenu précis de son
estomac et des causes de sa mort
survenue pourtant il ya plusieurs
milliers d'années aujourd'hui la
dépouille d'authie est exposé au musée
d'archéologie du tirol du sud j'espère
que cette vidéo vous a plu merci à
passer sauvage d'avoir participé à cet
épisode 6 l'archéologie l'anthropologie
et l'histoire vous passionne je vous
invite à visiter sa chaîne sans plus
tarder je vais vous mettre évidemment le
lien dans la description merci à tous
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo et merci à
toi fabien pour cette invitation je vous
embrasse et je vous dis à très vite
salut si vous ne connaissiez pas encore
va déjà bon jour ça fait plaisir je
m'appelle fabuleux car je m'appelle
toujours fabien olicard vous pouvez
activer la cloche vous abonner cliquez
cette vidéo ça fait plaisir le prochain
épisode de cabinet curieuse va être
publiés le mois prochain on va parler
d'un site légendaire qui est classée au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco qui est
très mystérieux vous en dit pas plus si
vous voulez encore être plus curieux je
vous invite à découvrir mon magazine qui
s'appelle que ryu c'est un vrai magazine
papier mensuel qui vient chaque mois
dans votre boîte aux lettres vous savez
pas trop ce que c'est vous savez pas
trop ce qu'on peut y trouver vous avez
le lien dans la description et vous
pouvez aller feuilleter les anciens
magazines pour voir un petit peu ce que
c'est et puis peut-être vous abonner à
ses magazines là aussi si ça vous plaît
ici je vous mets deux autres épisodes de
cabine et curieuse prenez soin de vous
très bientôt ciao
[Musique]
tous